très léger el famoso
m'attend c'est votre bureau
le conseil est très impressionné par oracle j'ai
décidé d'élargir vos responsabilités
votre secrétaire particulier votre jeune que
vous aviez toutes les qualités nécessaires a des yeux
je suis Frau Hoffmeister donc Ramiz enfin
tu es  l'assistant de mon mari et
je suis sa femme acceptons d'être francs les uns avec les autres d'
accord ou Fallon était-il étrangement une autre
chose quand elle joue le spittin it
touch of it oui il a proposé de donner
des cours supplémentaires OTO bientôt toute la famille
sous votre aile it  ce serait mieux si
tu quittais ton logement actuel et
emménageais ici trois libres je t'ai vu
c'est ridicule cette grande table
qui nous sépare
on ne peut pas continuer à faire ça en faisant quoi se mentir qu'est-ce que
tu imagines que le leadership mexicain
veut attirer des investissements  d'Europe les
filles pourquoi faire
et vous êtes tous de la vérité ce que je
vais aller au Mexique pendant deux ans deux enfants
n'ont jamais vieilli vous ne pouvez pas je viens avec moi
pourquoi ne m'avez-vous pas dit que
je ferai un  jure l'un à l'autre
je promets de s'aimer seule la
passion qui le touche est un gilet peut
allumer l'amadou de votre plus grande vérité
seulement à la main qui perd sa maison
quand soi est donné